[Applause] [Music] with our first pick we'd like
to select golender Mark Andre flurry
and there it is flurry goes first
overall hitting the arena ICE Mark Andre flurry
who will make his NHL [Music] debut there's not
many goal senders in the game that can
make that save I thought it was a goal
and the shut out tonight by Mark Andre flurry
his first ever the coolest part about it is
obviously see how good of a goalie he is but
the person he is is just it's incredible it
doesn't take long when you're around this
guy to understand why he has been beloved
everywhere he's been oh stop by flurry oh baby
oh mercy Mark Andre flurry just committed thy
a lot of us will never be around for someone
that's going to have that type of a career
and these types of Milestones so to be able
to do it together certainly special for the
guys fantastic save by Mark Andre
flurry his athleticism being able
to react and Di back hard wheeel save
by Mark Andre flurry spectacular work
not often you'll hear the fans of
the Bell Center cheering for the
opponent comes back to the point
R the shot knock down in front
shot another shot play the hard
sounds and the pay have W the St
[Music] Cup oh my goodness Mar godre flurry
that's one of the greatest saves I've ever
seen not only does he reach out with
the left hand and an elephantine glub
grab but there's panach on the tail end of it
there's just not much to say I mean let the
video do the talking this is something
else by Mark VRE flurry save that save
one of the best saves that you'll ever seen
wow and this seems wa about on the goal line
unbelievable C by against o right ahead is oan oh
a piece of it with furry that brings the crowd of
their face the showstopper for the flower very
special night here in Pittsburgh the return of
Mark Andre flurry [Music] probably one of the
last goalies to actually Entertain You watch
this save by Mark Andre furry are you kidding
me 500 career win game number 1000 they're in
awe of who he is as a player as a teammate
now flurry racing to get back into the net
sent it across and a glove save by flurry what a
sensational stop can only shake his head and Mark
Andre flurry has win number five 51 it's a huge
save by flower you know that's incredible what
he does he looks like 25 not like 50 never a dull
moment when that man's in net my Idols were Marty
brother fat a shut out for fur for 52 second
time passes Patrick my career 20 years it's G
by so fast it's insane look to the crowd flry
they're chanting one of those ones that gives
chills Andre
C